quick photo of your first season in
phoenix and you talked about how much
you love
being with the guys and i know it's
probably hard to reflect on that now
but just coming here and being able to
be a part of this what does this mean
for you personally
um i mean i'll take some time and think
about that but right now
uh you're just trying to figure out what
you're gonna do more
you know it's tough um great group of
guys
hell of a season but um this one's gonna
hurt for a while
mark spears good mark chris how would
you
say the locker room was like any way you
could describe what the emotions were
like in there
just lost so
um good rachel go ahead rachel oh you
got 11.
yeah um looking back at this whole
experience
just just i know you're shy but
i'm making it to the championship what
does it mean to finally reach this
pinnacle and have this experience
uh for me it just means back to work
back to work
you know nothing more nonetheless ain't
no moral victories
or whatnot uh we sort of saw what it
takes to get there and
you know hopefully we see what it takes
to get you know
past that knowing that for so long you
work to get to this point
is there any solace and hey i've had
this experience
and i can learn from it and i might get
back here
um i mean it'll take it'll take a while
to process this
or whatnot but it's same mentality get
back to work
you know what i mean i ain't retiring if
that's what you're asking that's out
so you know back to work
dwayne yeah chris with all dude
with all all due respect obviously you
got a decision to make